Dallas Maverick's owner mark cubin would
be willing to give Baylor women star
Britney Griner an opportunity to play on
the maps the problem is Britney grinder
would never make the Mavericks and it's
because she's a woman right we all know
that there's a reason that the WNBA
exists but Mark saying that and posting
a link to it yeah I'd give her a chance
well you'd give her a chance and she
would fail at it she would be crushed by
these people it's just the truth and we
all know it I'm glad she's that
confident in her abilities she's also a
little delusional and I'm better but um
and I know that that kind of gets at him
but it's okay it's okay it's okay little
man I got C on that I'm going to go to
the ATM and I'm going to sell my house
and I'm going to put all my money on
DeMarcus Cousins